[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous il ya eu
d'abord du bleu ensuite de l'orangé
maintenant du gris dans son caddie avec
contact entreprises toutes les couleurs
de l'économie décliné par l'association
patronale et son président emmanuel de
reno donald est avec nous dans son
réduit bonjour bonjour
après avoir incité emmanuel de reynal
des martiniquais à se tourner vers
l'économie bleue celle de la mer après
avoir donné des pistes pour rendre la
martinique attractive à travers votre
livre orange maintenant c'est le btp
avec le livre grille il était important
de dresser un état des lieux de ce
secteur qui mobilise quand même dix
mille salariés en martinique
oui c'était important car ce secteur est
en panne depuis de longues années et que
on sait que le btp est souvent la source
première d'un succès que 2 millions un
territoire et donc on ne peut pas ne pas
s'intéresser au btp non pas pour les
intérêts mains des hackers du btp mais
parce que c'est le moyen moyen essentiel
pour rendre territoire dynamique et
économiquement viable alors ce livre
c'est la faute aux deux moments un lit
ou bien livre de propositions qui sera
classée sans suite
alors d'abord avant de vous répondre je
vais vous dire la méthode parce que
c'est ce livre est important plus par la
méthode que par son contenu
dans ce livre il ya les contributions de
nombreux acteurs ça s'est fait au mois
de mars au château de la favorite nous
avons réuni pendant deux jours
l'ensemble des acteurs du btp mais aussi
quelques acteurs qui relève de l'état ou
des politiques ou des citoyens engagés
qui se sont mis autour de plusieurs
tables il y avait cette table ronde pour
réfléchir à des pistes de solution c'est
donc un travail coct construit ce n'est
pas la pensée unique de contact
entreprises c'est vraiment la synthèse
de contribution est donc cette méthode
je crois est la bonne
res et c'est que nous avions utilisé
pour le livre bleu et le livre orange
d'ailleurs c'est faire réfléchir
collectivement les différents acteurs
pour sortir des pistes et est-ce que ça
va susciter peu déclic auprès de qui
déjà à il faudrait que ça suscite des
déclics auprès de tous ceux qui ont
candé
levier aujourd'hui nous avons la chance
avec ce livre maintenant de disposer
d'une pensée synthétique de l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques liées au btp
avec à la fois une analyse sectorielle
de situation comment où on en est
aujourd'hui une vision prospective vais
à quoi devons-nous aller et puis des des
pistes claire concrète de solutions
décline en cinq chapitres
il ya là je crois matière à s'emparer du
sujet quand on est un politique résolue
pour pouvoir élaborer son plan ou son
plan d'action mais pas que le public et
papa que le politique également le privé
il faut dire que il peut avoir pas mal
d'initiatives de ce secteur privé qui
pourrait permettre au btp de repartir
tout simplement
oui c'est vrai que le btp est un sujet
qui concerne l'ensemble des décors de du
territoire les politiques aujourd'hui
ont besoin d'être alimentés pour pouvoir
structurer leur vision c'est souvent ce
qu'il manque d'ailleurs en martinique
c'est une vision politique vers où
doit-on aller et nous chan entreprises
modestement nous cherchons à apporter
nos contributions en apportant des
pistes de réflexion alors ces pistes de
réflexion doivent aider à la fois les
privés et à la fois les décideurs
politiques voire même les médias d'état
alors il vaut complète le projet
structurant qu'on a pu découvrir à
travers à travers ce livre des voix
supplémentaires de circulation il faut
favoriser cette mobilité
vous parlez d'une voie supplémentaire
nord sud par exemple
et puis vous évoquez par exemple 7 cette
route entre la brasserie lorraine et et
carrère le parc hôtelier la mise aux
normes de l'existant une norme tropicale
le logement social le plan au met tout
ça les politiques le savent dire oui ce
que nous avons cherché à faire c'est
heureux
rhj à pitre et les éléments dans des
dans un champ d'urgence ce qui est
intéressant dans ce livre grille du btp
c'est que il ya par exemple un chapitre
qui consiste à dire que la vision
première pour aider le btp à s'en sortir
et de s'accorder sur une stratégie
territoriale autour du tourisme c'est
pas banal parce que quand on parle de
tourisme a priori on est loin du btp or
c'est ce qu'il se dégage de ces travaux
c'est de dire que nous que le btp doit
se mettre service
d'une stratégie clairement assumé pour
pouvoir nous distinguer sur nos
territoires l'autorisent aujourd'hui est
sans doute la seule voie de sortie de la
martinique et on peut devenir une
destination touristique majeure
si on reconstruit d'avantagé un des
rites et les manuels de redal oui mais
bon enfin des hôtels mais je crois que
il ya une volonté a poussé aujourd'hui
il manque malgré tout des chambres
d'hôtel pour accueillir les flux
touristiques qui arrive il y a une vraie
stratégie ce nombre à 12000 chante qu'il
faudrait qu'ils aient les spécialistes
nous disent qu'aujourd'hui il manque
quatre mille chambres d'hôtel pour être
la destination de référence de la
caraïbe nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
ce qui est insuffisant et qui fait
précisément que par manque d'offre on
détourne clientèle donc aujourd'hui il
faut être un peu audacieux on a la
chance de bénéficier de flux
touristiques importants ce moment c'est
aussi un secteur qui fonctionne c'est
bien celui là
il faut donc accompagner ce mouvement
donc l'hôtellerie enfin le tourisme en
l'occurrence est sans doute le sas il a
marqué c'est inique exclusivement alors
c'est le privé dans le tourisme il a
plein d'idées qui tourisme le
spiritualisme par exemple pour nous et
le la pointe de la flèche pour tirer
l'économie touristique
là encore le privé est prêt s'il ya une
vraie volonté affirmée d'aller dans ce
sens qu'est ce qui bloque emmanuel de
finale ils n'ont qu'eux ils bloquent ce
qui bloque c'est peut-être d un manque
de cohésion dans les visions public
malheureusement nous sommes assez
désespéré de voir que les visions ne
s'enclenche pas qu'on reste sur du très
court terme et qu'on n'ose pas se
projeter dans un avenir clair
donc c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
faudrait d'une nouvelle classe de
décider tout simplement
il faudra en tout cas que les que les
décideurs aujourd'hui dialogue davantage
et mieux avec ceux qui apportent des
idées et de ne pas considérer qu'il ya
une compétition entre les uns et les
autres
aujourd'hui sur terre nous sommes terre
de colloque nous sommes terre de
conférence nous sommes terre de
séminaires on a on a cité les trois
livres publiés par contact entreprises
il y à d'autres associations d'autres
corps de métiers qui ont ce qui rend
publié également des livres blancs des
livres souci là des condensés en fait
bref des projets tout simplement oui
mais enfin je la faiblesse de penser que
ce que nous avons publié jusqu'à
aujourd'hui a eu des effets alors je
pense par exemple au livre bleu
aujourd'hui il ne vous a pas échappé que
l'économie bleus est devenu revenu au
centre du débat public et que ça inspire
maintenant des acteurs de manière très
opérationnelle
regardez ce qui se passe dans la ville
du marin aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
stratégie de la ville autour de
l'économie bleus et d'autres acteurs se
sont emparés de ce système le nautisme
cyr restructuré depuis que nous avons
lancé ce livre bleu est donc là je crois
qu'il ya des effets concrets qui en qui
se sont dégagés de ces travaux les
ateliers du rhum aidé à cannes que nous
avons monté il y a deux ans aujourd'hui
ont mis au centre du débat public et je
crois de au centre des consensus
l'idée que leurs hommes de martinique
doit être l'étendard de notre territoire
pour inspirer une stratégie audacieuse
ça c'est nouveau on parle de spirit ou
ris maintenant on n'en parlait pas ya
deux ans et je crois que là ce sont des
les mentalités qui évolue donc notre
rôle est de mettre sur la table ces
sujets là de faire réfléchir
et puis de laisser les intelligences ce
s'emparer de ces sujets pour construire
des projets aujourd'hui le tourisme
spiritualisme se structurent
concrètement regarder ce qui se passe
dans les distilleries il ya une vraie
une vraie orientation au moment nous
pouvons être attaqué sur la question des
quotas
absolument et c'est pour ça que c'est
important de poser le débat parce que
c'est en somme a quand même l'impression
que chaque fois qu'on veut avancer sur
une piste qu'il ya tout de suite une
difficulté qui arrive à le chemin est
tortueux il n'est pas facile
malheureusement c'est un travail de
longue haleine il faut convaincre il
faut rappeler et il faut faire en sorte
que demain il faut convaincre que c'est
la bonne voie et que tous ceux qui ont
des leviers autour de ces deux de ces
solutions doivent effectivement
accélérer leur processus pour permettre
au projet de bien sentir alors revenons
sur un exemple le plan aussi quand même
près de 70 millions qui sont là qui
pourrait être injecté dans tout ce qui
est canalisations restructuration de nos
tuyaux et cetera pourquoi ça patine
alors dans le livre grille nous avons
été effaré d'ailleurs dans un an c'est
un chapitre qui s'appelle construire la
sûreté aujourd'hui très clairement
globalement la martinique et en étant
déficiences dans ces grands équipements
et qui met nos populations en danger
donc là je pèse mes mots quand je dis ça
parce que c'est assez épouvantable et ça
concerne à la fois l'eau nous avons un
système d'eau qui manifestement n'est
pas aux normes
nous avons des dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres de canalisations qui sont
complètement défectueuse
elles ont 60 ans et plus pour certaines
d'entre elles on ne sait même pas
comment l'eau arrive jusqu'à nos
robinets parce qu'il traverse des zones
de terres qui ne sont même plus canalisé
et donc là il ya un vrai sujet nous
sommes très en retard et il y est cela
pose des problèmes de santé publique
donc le plan aux fins construire la
sûreté par l'eau reconstruire les
canalisations remettre à niveau nos
sienna cynisme en savent a été évalué à
peu près à 1 milliard d'euros donc on
parle de sommes considérables pour juste
nous mettre à un niveau normal et éviter
qu'une catastrophe vient dire qu'avec
lentement 10 coups de pioche
parce que je crois qu'il faut mettre sur
la table et sur le débat public ces
urgences les organisateurs l'ont fait on
avait reçu le responsable de deux
rapports blanc pillay
dit menad et il y à des sommes qui sont
là ne pourrait pas mais les la commande
il y à là manifestement une forme
d'impuissance qui est qui est
dommageable donc il faut trouver des
solutions pour que cette impuissance
s'abandonne au profit de solutions
nous préconisons nous devancent
l'urgence du problème de mobiliser nos
élus de mobiliser tous ceux qui peuvent
être mobilisés pour obtenir de l'état un
pays un plan exceptionnel
d'investissement
voilà une vraie mobilisation qui doivent
nous qui doit s'enclencher là de manière
collective et sans aucun aucune division
parce que là c'est un enjeu vital pour
notre territoire la corse a su le faire
en 2003 ils ont su mobiliser 2 milliards
d'investissements à travers un pays en
mobilisant l'état alors que la corse
compte 330 mille habitants nous nous
sommes un peu plus nous sommes en
déficit
contrairement à ce qu'on dit par rapport
à sur le critère de l'aide publique par
habitant à martinique par rapport à
l'hexagone en hexagone le l'aide
publique moyenne par habitant est
supérieur de 25% par rapport à l'aide
publique moyenne en martinique donc ne
serait ce que pour nous mettre à niveau
je crois que nous devons convaincre
l'état de mobiliser un pays pour régler
définitivement nos problèmes d'eau
d'assainissement et de sûreté en général
et vous dites également que les fonds
européens ne sont pas suffisamment
utilisé dans des projets structurants
ça c'est un fait aujourd'hui d'abord
globalement les fonds européens
ne sont pas bien géré ça s'éteint c'est
un constat qu'il faut faire froidement
je sais qu'il ya on se mobilise on agit
aujourd'hui pour essayer de rattraper le
retard mais le retard est là et on vous
reproche de faire dans la martinique
daqing oui mais je crois que la vérité
folle à dire à un moment donné faut dire
les choses il faut dire les faits moi je
me réfère un tableau qui a été publié
par le ministère des outre-mer récemment
qui montrent que nous sommes en dernière
position
donc ça ce n'est pas moi qui ai inventé
cette poésie shell broschi de la
commission finances de l'assemblée de
martinique elle vous disait que vous en
faisait peut-être un peu trop sur ce
dossier parce qu'aujourd'hui je déplore
que dia la vérité c'est ça prend des
tournures politique moi je ne savais pas
dans mon état d'esprit
il faut dire les choses si on veut les
régler il s'agit pas de désigner des
responsables et de les anesthésier il
s'agit de de poser des problèmes
et pan et derrière de se mobiliser pour
les régler aujourd'hui à une urgence
c'est de d'activer ces fonds européens
parce que derrière ces dossiers il y
aller les fonds européens au service
n'avait selon public
mais il ya aussi les aves les fonds
européens au service d'un avion privé et
je peux vous dire en tant que président
de contact entreprises que trop
d'entreprises sombrent et meurent parce
qu'elles n'arrivent pas à obtenir et à
déclencher leur z qui leur sont
naturellement du dernière question hors
10 secondes
ce livre gris ce livre orange il se
livre bleu sur des pubs programme
économique déjà il y a dans ses livres
les futures élections
il y a dans ce livre de quoi inspirer
des programmes pour ceux qui voudraient
s'en emparer merci beaucoup et manuel de
reina de l'avoir avec nous rappelle
qu'on est le président de l'association
patronale pour cette entreprise merci
d'avoir été dense en fait dit mme
mercier